listening to a film courage women
and Kerry Wood
talk Ryu
yeah I mean that this is a it's sort of
a complex thing and you know Jay and I
have become for whatever reason let a
little more harsh and the advice that we
give filmmakers lately and you know our
our thing is you know it usually takes
you quite a long time to develop your
filmmaking craft before you know what
you're doing to make a feature there are
of course exceptions to that rule I've
seen people who made like one short or
no shorts and make a good feature very
very rare and I think there's usually a
lot of luck involved you know most of my
friends my filmmaking companions we all
made shitty movies for ten years and
those are very important to make and
they're very important to make cheaply
and so our advice that we usually give
to filmmakers is go out and make shorts
make them digitally make them as cheaply
and as pain-free as you possibly can
because if you make an expensive one or
you spend a whole lot of time on it or
you know exhaust a lot of your resources
you're going to get really depressed
when it sucks and it's probably going to
suck because most people's early films
suck so our thing is really you really
shouldn't move on to features until you
have taken a short or two that are good
to festivals people have seen them
you've watched them in front of an
audience you know that you're connecting
with an audience and you know that like
okay this is kind of what I have to
offer the world I'm good at making these
kinds of movies so let me take this
microcosm of the short expand it into a
feature now that I know that it's
working